are people going to turn on jordan peele
if nope is not good
i'm hoping to get your thoughts on this
i found a 2017 article in the financial
review about steven spielberg and the
writer says
few great film directors are as picked
on as steven spielberg and then the
article continues to say partly this is
down to his outside success
which sits
ill at ease with our notion of an artist
i find that interesting do you think
success brings
a distrust of the artist after a while
it brings more criticism
for sure
because
when you have someone
like steven spielberg who raised the bar
so much very early on
i mean show us
what that did for like the horror movie
genre
you know and it's still talked about to
this day
jurassic park
schindler's list
the older he gets
the projects he takes on
they're not
as many home runs or they're not as
consistent
but i think he's making movies that are
more
what he wants to do he's kind of earned
the right to make the movies that he
wants to make
and that
piece
makes me immediately think of west side
story
because
there was so much criticism
around west side story
and i'm not saying that they were wrong
but there is a lot of criticism with the
latino culture about how they were
presented in the movie and how a certain
filmmaker should have been directing
that movie
but i think he's at a point where he's
kind of a legacy director and he's
earned his stripes
that if you're a studio
and steven spielberg walks into your
office and goes
hey
i want to remake
west side story
i don't really think anyone's going to
turn him down right and i think people
forget about that
and it there is a discussion to be had
there about
whether certain filmmakers really should
be tackling certain topics and
whether
other filmmakers would be better suited
for that
but i do think
you kind of earn
your right to do a lot of stuff when
you've proven yourself so much and so
much of
film history
is centered around what you accomplished
i mean close encounters i mean
indiana jones like there's so much stuff
that he has been
a part of
that you can't
take away from it's just like you kind
of get a pass you kind of get to do what
you want
but i do think that
the older
uh uh
a director becomes
the more criticism he faces and you you
don't have to just use steven spielberg
look at
martin scorsese how many how many people
have been
criticizing him more
clinton eastwood yeah
how many people criticize him now
i mean woody allen for other reasons but
i mean woody allen has always been
sort of a one-note filmmaker right it's
always a rich socialites getting
together for something he's been making
the same movie since the 80s but only
because of the controversy around him
that people start being like oh he's not
that good of a director it's like i
don't know he's like literally making
the same movie over and over again like
so if this is not good then those other
movies weren't that good either
so yeah i think at the end of the day
that's that's really what it comes down
to is that i think it's easy to become a
punching bag
but it's even more easy to be a punching
bag in a modern age
when you're an older white guy
it's something that i've i definitely
noticed
people are not afraid to throw older
white men underneath the bus anymore
and in terms of the the scope of west
side story i mean there were a lot of
cast members right so to give this to a
newer director
uh
would be i mean this is someone who's
directed large-scale
production so
not just his name but also
expertise i mean some some would argue
that he didn't have a background in
musicals
um
you know again
the story the subject matter is very
sensitive and it's again you're talking
about a movie that came out originally
in the 50s and people have problems with
that regardless of whether
reena rita moreno is in it they still
have problems with the way that that
story was told
and
people still view it as a classic but
again like a lot of movies made in
different generations they don't
necessarily
are up to par with the way things are
today
and i think that's the problem i think
if if steven spielberg wanted to remake
west side story in the 90s
the approach
and the criticism on it would have been
a lot different sure nowadays it's sort
of like no why didn't like
lin-manuel miranda direct that he would
have been a much better director he's
latino he would have gotten the
storyline he would have gave him more
emotion
you know and that movie also on unfairly
got a lot of
hate because of the whole
ansel elgort thing
and people criticizing them for like
nobody going and bashing him on that
tour which is like
i think people forget that
just because one person does something
crappy to one person
doesn't mean that he's crappy to
everyone you know this is not a harvey
weinstein situation on our hands
and sometimes people can get called out
and they can learn from their mistakes
and it also depends on the person's age
he's a young guy
we make a lot of bad decisions when
we're in high school in college before
and he probably just made a bad decision
so as long as he learns from it and
grows from it it's fine but that movie
i didn't love that movie but i feel like
that movie really got like
the [ __ ] end of the stick i don't know i
don't know how else to put it because i
feel like it was just always on the
chopping block for so many people
and so going forward and maybe younger
directors who
are earning their stripes is that
something that they will have to face
that that they will be once you get to
be a certain level now
you're just you you have a target on
your back basically
i mean it's so hard how everyone turns
on someone now right like
we saw with patty jenkins with 1984.
everyone loved wonder woman everyone
loved monster
and then all of a sudden everyone turned
like we we forget
that
filmmakers and actors
they're not perfect they take roles they
make movies
that sometimes don't work
or they don't connect they don't
resonate
and it's so weird because i don't know
how to answer that question because i
almost feel like it is dependent on a
person
like are people going to turn on jordan
peel
if nope is not good i don't know and and
then it becomes this weird conversation
about
is it a race thing
is it a sexual orientation thing
is it what the person stands for like
are we like
because jordan peele is such a
inspiring filmmaker and someone who's so
ambitious and takes chances and made two
movies that were very critically
acclaimed
is it okay because he's a person of
color who puts other people of color in
his movies for nope and i'm not saying i
don't know i haven't seen it but if nope
is not good
will he get the past because of all the
other things he he he's done or will
people turn on him and be like
i guess that gravy train's over this guy
is a terrible filmmaker what a terrible
movie
it's so hard to know anymore because you
watch everyone turn so quickly on
someone and it doesn't matter what it is
it's it's a really weird time to be in
this industry
because
you say one thing wrong and and a whole
entire group of people can turn against
you
you make one bad film
and it's like
they lost it
it's crazy i don't know
i mean it's it's such a it's such a
weird way to think because
we started this question with steven
spielberg
and i mean steven spielberg has
consistently made
a good movie and a bad movie a good
movie and a bad movie a good movie in a
bad movie
it's just the way that it is and again
it's all subjective
film
all art is subjective
what's bad to some might be good to
someone else